hi in this module i'm going to talk
about how to use feature templates to
organize and construct your features in
a very flexible way
so recall that a hypothesis class is a
set of all predictors that a learning
algorithm is going to consider
and then in case of linear predictors
we've looked at predictors
of a function of x to be equal to in the
case of regression w dot phi of x
or in the case of classification sine of
that quantity
and we allow the wave vectors to where
vary freely
okay so we can visualize the hypothesis
class as follows so imagine the space of
all possible predictors all possible
functions mapping x to y
when you define a feature extractor fee
what you're doing is committing to a
particular subset of all possible
predictors
and usually you do this by
using prior knowledge
and the second part is the learning
algorithm
where you're given script f the
hypothesis class you're asking the
learning algorithm to choose a
particular predictor from that set
based on data
so intuitively we want the script f
hypothesis class to
contain the good predictors of course
but it can also contain some bad ones
because they will will be filtered out
based on the basis of data but we don't
want it to be too big
so that the learning algorithm has a
trouble identifying good predictors from
the bad predictors
so let's look at an example task and i
want to give you an idea of how to
choose the feature extractor
so suppose you're given a string
such as abc gmail.com and you're asked
to predict
whether
this is a valid email address or not
using a linear classifier
so in this case what we have to do is to
identify the feature extractor fee
so when you're designing a feature
extractor the main question you ask
yourself is what properties of the input
x might be relevant for predicting why
of course you don't want to necessarily
commit to a particular aspect to be
important because you don't know that
you want to learn that from data
but you should give the learning
algorithm some guidance
so what we're going to do is define the
feature extractor as given x produce a
set of feature name feature value pairs
so in this particular example the
feature extractor is going to produce a
feature vector
and let's say if in this case we might
look at
the length
is it greater than 10
in case it's one because length
is has something to do with whether it's
a value address the fraction of
alphanumeric characters
0.85 in this case doesn't contain an at
sign that's one because it does contain
an x sign
ends with a com
and it's
one here
and does it end with dot org and it's
zero here
okay so this is a feature vector or that
we might construct for this particular
application
so now we go to prediction
so remember that we've previously
defined the feature vector to just be
a real vector it's just a list of
numbers so what we've done right now is
to just annotate or comment each
component of that feature vector with a
name that describes what that
component is about
we can do the same thing with the
corresponding wave vector so here is a
white vector just a list of numbers and
we can annotate each component with the
name of the corresponding field
and recall that the score is just the
dot product w dot phi of x
and just to write out the dot product
it's a
sum over all the features or components
of wj the weight of that feature times
the feature value
okay so here's an example
um the weight of length greater than 10
is minus 1.2
the the feature value is one so you have
that product here and you have all the
other features
so a little piece of intuition here is
that you can think about the score
remember in classification positive
scores are
uh result in positive classification
negative scores result in negative
classification you can think about each
feature as providing a
vote
you can think about if let's say phi of
x j is one
and w j if it's positive that means it's
vading in fo fading in favor of a
positive classification and if wj is
negative it's invading voting in favor
of negative classification and the
magnitude of wj determines the strength
of the vote
so that's another way to interpret
the dot product before we previously saw
that we can interpret as a cosine of the
angle which is a more geometric
interpretation
so so far we've seen that we can take
inputs define arbitrary features
extractors get out our feature vectors
and do learner
but
how do we choose these feature vectors i
i just kind of made up at com and org um
which ones do we include
so far we've used some primary knowledge
but um it's very easy
in this manner to miss some um what
about
suffixes like an enus for example
we need a more systematic way of doing
this
and this is where feature templates come
in it comes in so a feature template is
simply a group of features all computed
in a similar way
so here's an example so with the input
abc gmail.com
we're going to write the feature
template as simply an english
description
with a blank and that blank is meant to
be filled in with an arbitrary value
last three characters equals something
and by instantiating that blank with all
sorts of different
values then we begin to realize
the feature vectors
that are the features that are actually
defined by this feature template
so
the important part here is that
we no longer have to say which suffixes
are important we don't have to say what
types of patterns
what particular patterns to look at we
just have to know that there exists
some suffix
that might be important in define this
feature template letting the learning
algorithm sort out which of these many
features are actually relevant
so to continue this example so the input
is abc gmail.com we define this feature
template which can be instantiated uh by
substituting something like dot com
um we can also define this other feature
template length greater than blank
and we can type plug in one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten and
so on into that
um some feature templates
are don't have a blank and that's okay
because that just corresponds to specify
one single feature and that has a
particular value
so here's another example so suppose the
input is an aerial image along with some
metadata about the location
so you can go figure out where this
actually is
um
so the feature template in this case we
might want to look at the following so
we want to look at the pixel intensity
of this image at a particular row
and a particular column
and it's a color image so there's three
channels rgb so we for identify a
particular channel that we're looking at
so this might be instantiated as the
pixel intensity of image at row 10 and
column 93
red channel and that might have a
particular value
another feature template might look at
the metadata the location
and be
a feature on whether the latitude is in
a particular range and longitude is in a
particular range
so
this feature template gets instantiated
might be essentially with um
particular values that uh denote ranges
um
so this is if you remember um piecewise
constant features this is an example of
piecewise constant features that carves
up the
um the
the world into a bunch of regions and
has a feature firing if the
lat long is in a particular region or
not
so one thing you might know is that
feature templates are pretty flexible
but sometimes they can give rise to a
lot of features last character equals
blank and there's already you know 26 if
you only include a lowercase letters
and furthermore most of these feature
values are zero
so in these cases this is what we mean
when a feature vector is sparse and you
can actually represent sparse feature
vectors
by more compactly by just as a
dictionary mapping the feature name to
the actual feature value
so in general there's two ways you can
represent feature vectors one is using
arrays and one is using dictionaries
so if your feature vector looks like
this which is dense or not sparse
that means all the feature values are
mostly non-zero
then you might want to just represent
this as an array order the feature
somehow and just list out the numbers
but in cases where your feature vector
looks like this and has lots of zeros
then it will be more efficient to
represent this as a dictionary where you
again you specify the feature name colon
the
feature value of only the non-zero
elements and by a convention anything
that is not mentioned has a value of
zero
so one interesting advantage of sparse
features is that you don't have to ins a
priori instantiate all the features in
advance you can kind of as data comes
you only kind of lazily build up these
features over time whereas if you were
doing
things in a dense way
you would have to
pre-define the fixed set of features
that you're going to be working with now
in recent years with deep learning dense
features have and arrays have been much
more ubiquitous
partly because you can take advantage of
fast
matrix computations on the gpu
so to summarize
we want to identify hypothesis classes
and in this case we're looking at
defining the hypothesis class with
respect to the feature extractor
to define the feature of extractor we
use feature templates which is a
convenient shorthand for unrolling a
feature single feature template into a
bunch of different features we also saw
that in some cases the feature vectors
were sparse and therefore you can use a
dictionary implementation to be more
efficient
okay so that's the end of this module
thanks